le 78 sport sur TVfil 78 bonsoir
bienvenue si vous venez de nous
rejoindre pour cette première édition de
ce rendez-vous sport bonsoir Anthony
bonsoir wilfri oui chaque semaine
maintenant vous aurez 26 minutes pour
faire l'ACT le tour de l'actualité Sport
dans le département et aujourd'hui nous
parlons football avec Mustapha Larbaoui
président de on peut dire le nouveau
club l'Étoile Sportive de de trappe mais
aussi tennis de table avec geoffrein
nzan et Salomé la porta vous êtes
respectivement entraîneur et capitaine
de l'équipe première de voisin
saintarnou bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir
bonsoir et on débute par le football oui
football priorité au football parce que
c'est là que tu chaudes un petit peu on
va dire mustaapha il y a un nouveau nom
un nouveau cap qui est en train de se
lancer du côté du du du football de
traap pourquoi ce nouveau nom étoile
sportive de Trapp alors avant tout merci
de nous inviter pour cette première
c'est c'est un grand honneur que vous
nous n fait et bonjour aux
téléspectateurs en fait faut bien savoir
qu'on est quand même au trap
Saint-Quentin Football Club encore ce
soir ça reste le logo ce soir jusqu'à la
fin de la saison sur les équipements et
bien évidemment nous sommes je suis
président mais je suis également
légaliste ça suppose que le nom changera
à l'issue d'une assemblée générale
extraordinaire en tout cas vous voulez
que ce nom change en toutous les cas
c'est c'est ma position voilà alors
expliquez-nous pourquoi alors tout
simplement parce que voilà euh nous
avons fêté les 80 ans le reportage je le
montrai tout à l'heure les 80 ans du
club et également les 10 ans de ma
présidence euh tout le monde et là c'est
pas moi qui parle c'est tout le monde
dit ça a changé c'est le mot qui revient
constamment ça a changé l'état d'esprit
a changé il y a plus de problème de
discipline on n'est pas en commission de
discipline au district les résultats
sont là vous les connaissez on peut les
rappeler aux téléspectateurs mais c'est
vrai que globalement pour les U13 les
U15 les U17 les U19 les seigneurs vous
avez vu les résultat tout à l'heure les
résultats sont là bref l'état d'esprit a
changé tout a changé les équipements a
changé et puis je me suis rendu compte
que le logo n'avait jamais changé et
alors donc avec bien sûr tous mes amis
le groupe du trap SaintQuentin Football
Club on s'est dit et si on changeait de
logo donc on a commencé à discuter
autour du logo donc les couleurs sont
apparu plus facilement avec les symboles
et puis j'ai eu
effectivement j'ai un peu poussé moi je
vais l'assumer seul euh ça sera voté
bien évidemment fin juin si c'est voté
j'ai poussé seul sur cette idée que il y
a un moment où le club était ex
extraordinairement en vue c'est quand il
s'appelait l'Étoile sportive des
chemineaux de trappe donc avant le strap
Saint-Quentin Football Club et et et
j'ai eu envie j'ai eu cette idée de dire
mais finalement qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
depuis 10 ans on est revenu aux sources
du football on est revenu à la méthode
on est revenu à la méthode des anciens
je vous interrom il y a un mot qui
disparaît un nom qui disparaît c'est 5
quenttin en Eveline il il disparaît il
disparaît oui tout simplement parce que
c'est pas unodin non puisqu'on revient à
l'Étoile Sportive de trappe qui est le
premier nom celui qui a été créé en 1933
c'est faire honneur aux ancêtres c'est
faire honneur au football c'est faire en
au retour aux sources et en même temps
Saint-Quentin pour moi représente le
verbe avoir Saint-Quentin on l'a collé
je ne sais pas pourquoi à une époque où
je n'étais pas là pour des subventions
pour avoir de l'argent pour avoir des
subventions pour avoir éventuellement
une vision je sais pas quoi on n jamais
eu pire résultat que dans cette période
je suis revenu au verbe être pas au
verbe avoir donc ça veut dire que vous
n'avez plus les subvention voilà ça veut
dire quoi il y a un problème de
subvention entre la la communauté
d'agglomération de 5 et le club de
trappe c'est pour ça que le ces
initiales SQ y s'en vont alors encore
une fois je répète ce n'est pas contre
trap 51 Football Club que je me présente
avec ce logo c'est pour les anciens
c'est pour la méthode c'est pour le
retour aux sources c'est pour c'est pas
contre Pr prièrement deuxièmement
problème de subvention c'est pas le
verbe avoir qui m'intéresse encore une
fois je l'ai dit c'est l'auxiliaire être
nous sommes trapistes nous sommes
footballeurs nous sommes au travail et
non pas j'ai besoin j'ai besoin vous
êtes à 50 ans ai et nous sommes à 50 ans
en effet sauf que pu que vous m'endre à
conjuguer avec cette première édition du
7 h sport ce
soir je vous invite je vous invite à
décliner le verbe être effectivement
mais le verbe avoir effectivement il
existe aussi simplement pour être précis
vous avez raison moi quand je suis
arrivé il a 10 an on m'a retiré une
partie de mes subventions sur l'idée que
le club était descendé d'un niveau soit
je connais la règle le club a continué à
descendre d'un niveau on n a retiré
encore je connaissais la règle on est
remonté deux fois j'ai pas vu la couleur
de l'argent deux fois premièrement et
deuxièmement si je peux me permettre
c'est pas l'argent qui a fait les
résultats d'aujourd'hui la preuve c'est
qu'on l'avait pas cet argent donc on a
bien fait sans cet argent on a fait par
le travail par la discipline et puis en
plus les gars quand vous leur dit ici
c'est ils disent pas ici c'est tsqfc SQ
au milieu c'est un peu compliqué ici
c'est vous les avez entendu ici c'est
Putra ici c'est pra donc ici c'est trra
Football Club pourquoi pas le Petra
Football Club
alors vous disiez juste à l'instant que
les vous n'avez pas vu la couleur de
l'argent ça veut dire que le retour de
de de l'argent qui qui vous avait été
supprimé suite aux descentes ça veut
dire que cette suppression de ces trois
lettres SQY c'est on peut parler de
divorce avec la communauté
d'agglomération oh ben c'est c'est pas
un mot que j'emploirai le divorce il a
été employé par Le Parisien c'est pas
d'abord un divorce ilut encore faut-il
qu'on se soit marié et qui a eu un
contrat on a eu des contrats de
subvention annuels et ben les contrats
sont assit reconductibles ou pas donc
c'est pas un divorce c'est une non
reconduction j'aime pas les divorces je
préfère les choses à l'amiable ça
s'appelle l'Étoile Sportive de trappe ça
failli s'appeler l'entente donc voyez on
on entente mais on reste dans trappe on
reste quand même à 50 ans en yeline ça
simplement je vais qu'on rfléchisse à
quelque chose dans le sport parce que
moi ce qui m'interpelle le plus c'est
pas tant de pas avoiri cette argent
puisqu'on a fait s l'argent ce qui
m'interpelle c'est qu'on donne de
l'argent à des niveaux or les niveaux de
certains clubs sont de bon niveau parce
qu'il y a de l'argent et pour le coup on
paye des des mercenaire on paye des gens
qui viennent de l'extérieur moi l'argent
je le mets sur l'éducateur je le mets
sur les éducateurs je le mets sur les
enfants je le mets sur le travail je le
mets sur le verbe être et non pas sur le
verbe avoir pour donner ça à des gens
qui viennent de l'extérieur d'ailleurs
tous ceux qu' ont fait le bonheur des
grands clubs comme certains clubs que je
ne citerai pas de la de la communauté ou
d'ailleurs ont fait le bonheur entre
guillemets des clubs ce sont des
trapistes qui étit payé par des
subventions comme des mercenaires
aujourd'hui c'est un réservoir de
joueurs mais un réservoir qui est
maintenant hermétique on ne part plus de
trapppe on reste à trappe parce qu'on
aime not trappe et parce que nous sommes
trappiste vous parlez de la des
éducateurs la formation c'est c'est un
autre axe de travail que vous avez
influé depuis depuis plusieurs années
chez les jeunes ça fonctionne bien on
sait que les les U15 les eu 13 on est
dans en DHR en DSR ça fonctionne très
bien et justement à ce propos je vous
propose d'écouter sur ce sujet-là
aussine m qui est un de vos éducateurs
l'éducateur des desu15 des moins de 15
ans on l'a interviewé on lui a posé la
question lors de la cérémonie samedi
soir c'est le travail de de 4 5 ans qui
se payent donc on les a depuis qui sont
en catégorie audition chez nous donc
c'est un suivi un bon travail à l'école
de foot l'entraînement donc le travail
parce que le travail euh c'est ce qu'on
leur apprend à l'école donc on veut que
ça revienne aussi au foot après c'est
tout ce qui est respect solidarité
travail collectif et tout va au travail
on va dire le mot travail travail
travail pour arriver un jour à à un
niveau on entend là plusieurs fois
répéter le mot travail c'est le nouvel
axe de de trappp j'ai l'impression
depuis 4 5 ans sur les sur l'avenir là
parce qu'on parlait des jeunes c'est
sûrement l'avenir du club hein avec avec
toutes ces équipes qui brillent non
alors l'avenir on est surtout dans la
continuité en fait on a on n pas la
prétention de dire que notre avenir va
s'écrire et on va simplement l'écrire et
on va le faire on le construit de la
même façon husin l'a dit il a encore
Gané ce weekend je rappelle quand même
que c'est quand même le plus haut niveau
que nous ayons dans la région bientôt la
DH et peut-être même des nationaux le
travail ouais c'est le mettre au mot
mais en fait le vrai axe depuis 10 ans
c'est l'école et on est labellisée école
de foot et en fait moi je suis un enfant
de la République issu de l'école
pharmacien et c'est l'école qui m'a
construit c'est l'école qui m'a tout
apporté donc en fait je me dirige je me
considère comme directeur d'école avec
des professeurs et on fait classe et on
fait des entraînements et on fait des
devoirs et on a des résultats et ce qui
m'intéresse surtout c'est la manière
donc la résultante pas forcément les
résultats donc en fait c'est la
continuité les U15 d'aujourd'hui sont
les U20 de demain et les U20
d'aujourd'hui sont déjà ceux qui sont en
train de faire gagner la première comme
on l'a vu hier c'est des Hu particul
donc vous voulez que ces jeunes restent
au club on l'a bien entendu vous êtes
fier de vos couleurs fierers de trappe
Mustapha L B oui merci d'être venu je
vous propose de rester encore avec nous
sur cette édition du 78 sport juste une
dernière question mais comme on est pris
par le temps vous ne pourrez répondre
que par OUI ou que par non si
l'agglomération de 50 ans en yelin
augmente ses subventions d'ici le mois
de juin est-ce que vous voterez le
changement de nom et vous ferez
disparaître 50 ans en yelin du N la
réponse c'est oui nous resterons sur le
verbe être et pas sur le verb à voir si
les subventions augmentent vous gardez
le nom c'est pas une question d' ou non
si les subventions augmentai vous gardez
le nom ou pas non je suis pas venu pour
kemander ce soir je suis venu pour dire
que nous changerons non non non non pas
du tout je l'ai jamais mise je la
mettrai JAMA merci beaucoup on passe au
badminton transition badminton c'était
la dernière journée de la phase allée
pour le club de badminton de de Montini
qui évolu en championnat de France en
National 3 les éontains recevaient le
lagardair Paris Racing ce weekend
secondde de la poule avec en ligne de
mire le maintien image d'éod moine la
fin de la phase allée d'un championnat
est souvent un tournant dans une saison
face au Paris la garder Racing le
challenge semblait compliqué à relever
pour le Badminton Club de Montini mais
les badurs inimtin restai sur deux
victoires consécutives après un départ
manqué et deux défaites face au poids
lourd du championnat des succès qui ont
permis à l'équipe cinquantinoise de
s'unir dans la difficulté la dernière
journée s'est bien passée on a réussi à
gagner des
matchs qui ont fait se souder l'équipe
je trouve et c'était plutôt positif sur
la fin de la sur la dernière journée là
c'était on sentait vraiment une bonne
ambiance entre les joueurs dans l'équipe
on reste confiance si on arrive à faire
une deuxième partie comme la première ce
sera ça sera très bien pour nous sur le
papier les joueurs Nimon ont moins
d'expérience et sont moins bien classés
que ceux des équipes leaders comme le
Racing ou l'ilbon tous de première série
l'objectif de départ était de figurer
parmi les quatre premiers de la poule ce
qui assure le maintien dans la division
pour l'instant Montini 4e accroche le
bon wagon le Bilon est plutôt positif
puisquon a deux défaites et deux
victoires donc pour l'instant on est 4e
du classement donc on se maintient donc
c'est l'objectif est pour l'instant
réalisé malgré toute sa greinta l'équipe
de Philippe Gomez s'est incliné face au
Racing et et plutôt sèchement 7 match à
un le 78 sport qui se poursuit on
l'espère ce sera un peu plus calme pour
la suite oui ça devrait aller avec le le
tennis de table autour de la table
geoffréizan et Salomé la porta vous êtes
respectivement entraîneur et capitaine
de l'équipe première de de de l'Entente
voisin satarnou qui qui fait de belles
belles choses et belles prouesses en ce
moment bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir donc
avant de parler de vos ambitions pour
cette nouvelle saison donc où vous allez
évoluer en National 2 je vous propose de
voir le portrait de votre équipe Salomé
que j'ai suivi avant les fêtes lors d'un
entraînement une équipe où expérience et
jeunesse bah se marie à
merveille le cercle vertuux de la
victoire et l'obsession de tous les
entraîneurs au club de tennis de table
de voisin le Bretonneux Geoffrey Nizan
ne connaît pas ce problème en l'espace
d'une année ces joueuses n'ont connu la
défaite qu'à une seule reprise face à
rambbouiller un bilan quasi parfait
accompagné de deux montées successives
historiques qui ne leur donne pas pour
autant la grosse tête non enfin faut
garder les pieds sur terre mais ouais on
est contente non non on s pas on a on a
quand on a commencé on était en préation
en prénational on était en pré
naationale et donc le niveau il était il
était un peu facile par rapport au par
rapport à aux autres équipes on sent pas
invincible on a perdu toutes des matchs
et on en perdra encore donc on reste les
pieds sur terre comme dirait Camille
l'équipe cinquantinoise est un parfait
mélange d'expérience et de jeunesse
entre la capitaine Salomé la porta 27
ans ancienne joueuse d'lancours habitué
des championnats nationaux et la précoce
Camille conen 15 ans il y a 13 années et
des dizaines de matchs les filles de
jofrenisan jouent dans le bon tempo mais
leur entraîneur se doit d'être de plus
en plus exigeant c'est partagé c'estàd
que oui on va au niveau des matchs en se
disant ça va être facile on va gagner
mais c'est difficile dans le sens où il
y a parfois un manque de motivation on
sait qu'on va aller faire un match où
les filles vont jouer sur des filles
moins fortes c'est difficile à gérer
dans le sens où on a n pas le droit à
l'erreur non plus vu qu'on veut monter
cette réussite est symbolisée par berang
Gerle surnommé la berun pour son jeu de
frappe en un an et demi elle a gagner
presque 500 points de classement et ce
succès l'équipe vcinoise le construit
aussi en dehors du terrain une bonne
complicité on rigole beaucoup on essaie
de faire des choses en dehors du tennis
de table ensemble après les matchs ou
les weekends donc ça nous permet d'être
vraiment solidaire solidaire et joueuse
de l'Entente voisin saintarnou devront
l'être pour se maintenir en National 2
premier match à Poitier le 19 janvier on
parle donc tennis de table et on
voudrait quelques explications sur ce
surnom la bûcheronne pourquo la surnomme
comme ça
Beranger elle est pas très délicate
c'estd que dans la B on va dire elle
tape très bien elle tape fort mais quand
il s'agit de jouer du petit jeu c'est un
peu plus
compliqué alors sur sur ce championnat
de National 2 votre premier match c'est
un déplacement à Poitier ça va déjà être
une une rencontre décisive Geoffrey oui
puisque donc on est tombé dans une poule
de National 2 c'est compliqué avec trois
équipes qui ont une équipe une en pro
donc il peuvent faire descendre des
joueur de pro don Poitier don il en
cours don Poitier donc Poitier c'est une
équipe abordable bien sûr s'ils font pas
jouer de fille de pro ce serait ce
serait plus sympa mais même s'ils font
jouer une fille de pro va falloir aller
se battre pour aller chercher le le
match et alors sur la saison de National
2 là vos objectifs quel quels vont être
ça va être le maintien ouais on peut pas
on reste raisonnable on reste
raisonnable parce que c'est la première
fois où on va jouer dans une division à
notre niveau donc va falloir montrer ce
qu'on sait faire face à des filles qui
ont le même niveau que nous et donc
match plus difficile mais il y a des
matchs quand même jouables dans cette
poule il y a pas que des que des cador
avec vous t tous les par exemple il vous
faut combien de victoires pour pour vous
maintenir parce que vous avez 7 matchs
c'est ça à jouer avec deux victoires on
est bien avec une troisème on est sûr de
se maintenir et alors du côté du côté de
la capitaine le le moral est tobau fixe
après c'est c'est de monter success
l'équipe a l'air a l'air vraiment
enchanté de l'idée de de se confronter
aux équipes de National 2 non ouais on
va enfin avoir des match à notre niveau
même si la poule est assez du on est
prête à jouer à ce niveaul et alors il y
aura un derby je crois que c'est un peu
un retour aux sources pour bah tous les
deux en fait puisque vous êtes issu de
des lancours je crois ça va être ça va
être un peu tendu ça va être une
atmosphère particulière forcément on va
retourner dans une salle où on connaitt
tout le monde il y a Aurore qui a joué
aussi à encour donc on sera même C à
retourner là où on a commencé et alors
au niveau moral vous enant dans au sein
des joueus il y a des discussions sur
sur ce maintien c'est jouable bon il y a
les ambitions du coach évidemment mais
du côté des joueuses on a envie de
savoir aussi vous pensez que c'est c'est
jouable en terme de niveau oui on pense
on en a pas encore beaucoup discuté on
attend de voir je pense les premiers
matchs et ce que ça va donner on verra à
ce moment-là mais on part confiante
on comme le comme Geoffrey le disait
pendant le sujet
elle n'avait pas le droit à l'erreur du
fait de de ce statut de de favoris là
vous allez jouer peut-être avec un petit
peu moins de pression ça va être
peut-être un peu plus libéré non là on
est pas là pour gagner tous les matchs
on sait qu'on doit en gagner deux trois
ça serait bien plus ça serait super donc
il y aura moins de pression sur tous les
matchs et ça c'est aussi plus
confortable pour l'entraîneur je pense
dans dans la préparation mentale des
rencontres ouis c'est sûr parce qu'on on
va partir sur les matchs avec d'autres
un autre discours en essayant de de
mettre les joueuses dans les meilleures
conditions mais en sachant très bien que
la défaite
elle pénalise pas l'équipe pour la suite
du championnat donc c'est important mais
est-ce que vous déjà vous ambitionnez
au-delà de cette propre saison donc on
rappelle he c'est des semestres au
tennis de table donc ça joue sur 6 mois
donc c'est très intensif vous vous vous
projetez déjà sur fin 2013 début 2014
avec ces mêmes joueuses parce que il y a
des joueuses très très jeunes en fait à
voisin on aimerait bien rester avec ces
cinq joueuses ce serait bien alors après
Berenger qui termine ses études qui veut
faire une école d'infir ère on sait pas
trop ce que ça donnera l'année
prochaine ensuite on a une autre jeune
fille donc qui est encore plus jeune que
Banger qui joue pas dans cette équipe
mais on aimerait bien construire une
deuxième équipe fille autour de cette
fille là donc c'est Sarah donc voilà
c'est les objectifs maintenir cette
équipe là à ce niveau et essayer de
monter la deuxième équipe pour réduire
l'écart entre entre l'équipe une et
l'équipe 2 oui parce qu'en fait vous
avez déjà un effectif plutôt intéressant
au niveau de l'équipe une mais il y en a
toujours une qui est un peu entre
guillemets écartée hein c'est un peu la
liste on essaie de faire une short list
pour le jour du match donc du coup quand
elle redescend pour l'équipe 2 aider
l'équipe 2 c'est moins intéressant c'est
ça c'est beaucoup moins intéressant et
puis surtout il y a un système de
brûlage au tennis de table qui dit que
quand on a joué deux matchs en dans
l'équipe une on a plus le droit d'aller
jouer dans l'équipe 2 donc c'est faut
faire en sorte qu'on puisse faire
tourner les filles et pas en sortir une
et qu'elle puisse plus jouer ensuite
quoi on parlait des subventions tout à
l'heure du côté duub de
Trapp qui est resté avec nous comment se
porte les subventions ce qui concerne le
club de bretonn en tennis de table je
vais laisser la secrétaire en parler
secrétaire capitaine et secrétaire du
club en même
temps bah on pourrait aller aussi je
penseoup
est moins énervé quand même c'est une
autre méthode une autre façon de en tout
cas les subvention ça reste compliqué
pour pe budget et on a pas pour
l'instant d'énormes subventions donc on
travaille là-dessus on va essayer de
rechercher des sponsor mais vous gardez
le nom de l'Entente on garde nom
deentente je vais je vais réussir à
fâcher Mustapha l je vais y arriver on
va peut-être récupérer les initiales
SQ j'offre sur sur cette équipe première
est-ce qu'elle joue un peu le rôle de
locomotive au sein du club parce que il
me semble qu'il y a 7 saisons vous étiez
à 25 adhérents donc c'està-dire presque
rien le club est passé en en 7 ans à de
25 à 120 adhérents donc c'est c'est
c'est un signal fort aussi bah pour
d'éventuelles subventions par exemple
vous vous y mettez aussi Anthony bravo
ou effectivement on a une bonne
évolution c'est partagé en en deux
phases une phase où on essaie d'évoluer
au niveau de la masse et donc c'est vrai
que maintenant au niveau des résultats
sportifs l'équipe une féminine permet de
tirer le club Verlot tous les jeunes
quoi sur les matchs à domicile on est 40
50 personnes à venir voir et c'est les
jeunes du club qui viennent voir
l'équipe donc c'est plutôt intéressant
merci beaucoup à tous les deux
d'êtreevenenu ce soir ce soir sur le
plateau de TVfil et puis on suivra donc
cette découverte de la Nationale 2 dans
dans les 6 prochains mois et bonne
chance à vous pour pour cette nouvelle
saison mer le 78 sport la suite c'est
avec les résultats du football et
toujours du football et on on va
reparler de de l'Étoile Sportive de
trappe he qui a inauguré un peu son son
futur nouveau nom ce weekend avec une
belle victoire he face à Saint-Leu
pourtant les joueurs cinquantinois se
font surprendre sur ce centre venu de de
l'aile droite mais ils réduisent le
score toujours en première mi-temps sur
coup de pied arrêté sur une déviation de
la tête de de Dominique Mendy pour
finalement s'imposer tris buts à 1 et
avec cette victoire les les trapistes
remontent sur le podium he de de leur
poule de promotion d'honneur avec 25
points à 7 points du du leader plutôt du
football féminin à présent oui vous vous
souvenez Wilfried le 2 décembre dernier
la rencontre de Division 2 féminine
entre Laas Montini et éepinal avait été
annulé car le club spinalien n'avait pas
pu se rendre au stade cquantinois faute
de faute de bus qui pouvait braver la
neige la Commission fédérale des des
compétitions nationales a octroyé la
victoire sur tapis vert aux in montaines
qui remonte du coup à la 4e place de
Division 2 ça fait forcément les
affaires du club local du club de
saint-qutin en iveline championnat de
France de National de masculin c'est en
basket basket on va aller voir les
l'étoile des chemin de trappe
malheureusement qui s'est incliné he sur
le parquet du leader Berk une petite
défaite 66 à 54 les joueurs de de
mostafha et la FIDI restent lanterne
rouge de leur poule avec seulement 19
points pris en 15 journée de leur côté
les féminines de l'Entente le chîn et
Versailles début 2013 comme elles ont
fini 2012 par une victoire dans dans le
choc de cette 13e journée elles se sont
imposé chez leur dauphin Calais de
justesse 61 à 58 et creuse un peu plus
les l'écart en tête du championnat de de
National 2 avec TR points d'avance sur
Bourges le vent des globes se poursuit
avec des fortunes diverses pour les
différents participants et nous suivons
comme chaque semaine nous faisons un
petit point sur le versaillais qui
participe à C comp de la M voilà après
57 jours de course c'est toujours
François gabar en tête he qui mène la
flotte au coude à coude avec Carmel le
Cléach pourtant GUID de la mot le marin
versaillais ben il est remonté à la 11e
place il navigue aujourd'hui à une
moyenne de 14 ne en ce moment il est
dans l'océan Pacifique Sud ce matin il
le skippper a connu quand même un petit
ennui mécanique il a dû réparer sa grand
voile qui était déchiré en son centre
petit collage de fortune et puis bah
c'est reparti hein comme il le dit sur
ses vidéos sur l'eau ce profil le
mythique caporn au tout au sud à la
pointe sud de l'Amérique Sud l'Amérique
du Sud pour le skipper d'initiative cœur
mais avant ce passage délicat un temps
redouté Tangui de la mote a tenu à fêter
à tous les tous les ivelinois la bonne
année
écoutez salut à tous Bienvenue à bord
d'initiative cœur je voulais vu qu'on
est sur le fuseauire de Auckland on est
les premiers à passer en 2013 alors je
voulais vous souhaiter une bonne année
2013 yop là allez bonne
allenée ah comme quoi quand on quand on
est sur la mer on a quand même le temps
de boire un peu de champagne pour la
bonne année et petite note heureuse he
grâce au clic hein vous savez que le
skippper d'initiative cœur permet de de
sauver des enfants par par son parcours
et un 6e enfant pu être sauvé un petit
GIPS âgé de 7 ans et qui vient du Bénin
et pour conclure cette première édition
du 78 sport Anthony les tops et les
flops de 2012 oui on on va regarder dans
dans le rétroviseur un petit peu 2012 he
pour finir auront des satisfactions
après cette première moitié de saison le
plaisir Rugby Club du rugby le PRC est
3e de de sa poule de fédéral 3 avec 26
points il est dans le bon wagon pour
décrocher son billet pour les play-offs
mais pour éviter toute mauvaise surprise
he les joueurs de Philippe Bard devront
faire preuve de plus de régularité et
prendre des points importants face au
concurent direct comme ponokobo Vitri ou
bord de mararne la la reprise promet en
tout cas d'être difficile hein dans les
semaines à venir avec des matchs chez le
second Orléan et la réception du leader
Bovet du tennis de table aussi parmi vos
top de l'année le tennis de table le le
le futur concurrent de de voisin le
Bretonneux c'est le CTT hlencour c'est
cette autre satisfaction hein de cette
première moitié de saison les pongistes
d'élencour sont actuellement 3e de probé
à la grande surprise malgré un léger fau
pas face à l'avant-dernier Mayenne
l'équipe cquantinoise renforcée à
l'intersaison par la venue de la numéro
1 grec Maria christophoraki continue de
surprendre tout à fait dans ce
championnat de probé dont le maintien
l'objectif en début de saison Wilfried
devrait être vite assuré un regard sur
les résultats au-delà de l'aspect
compétition puisque ce sont aussi vos
adversaires sur le le parcours des
encours en ProB oui tout à fait bah ils
ont un beau parcours ils partent pas
forcément favoris on sait que le c'est
une grosse division au niveau de la Pro
ils ont quand même
Yanan qui est assez solide qui doit être
la meilleure joueuse ou la deuxième
meilleure joueuse du top t donc ça
rapporte déjà deux points après c'est
aux autres de faire le boulot mais ça
permet d'intégrer des jeunes comme
pénelope et on souhaite le même parcours
également pour votre club au même niveau
bien évidemment le coup de cœur Anthony
le coup de cœur et ben il va lees Guill
en cours désolé mustouapha mais le club
de football brille en ce début de saison
chez les seniors l'équipe première éant
tête de promotion d'honneur avec
seulement deux défaites pour cette
victoires et 32 points au compteur et il
pe les gu en cortois possède la
meilleure attaque de leur championnat de
PH avec 21 buts inscrit mais aussi chez
les jeunes les U19 un Caracol en tête de
leur championnat et surtout il réalise
les poopées de cette saison en Coupe
gomardellaa ce dimanche 13 janvier ils
vont écrire l'histoire de leur club lors
des 64e de finale face à le grand
agioser c'est la toute première fois
dans l'histoire du club qu'une équipe de
jeunes atteint ce stade de la
compétition et TVfil se se mobilise he
pour pour l'occasion Wilfried vous
pourrez vivre et voir la semaine
prochaine un film retraçant toute la
préparation de l'équipe avant ce match
si capital en coupe gambardela dans le
prochain 7 Hu sport il vous reste 15
secondes Anthony pas une de plus pour le
flop de cette année 2012 c'est pas
gentil mais on peut l'oublier oui le
flop hein c'est c'est ça va du côté du
du trap basket l'étoile des cheminés de
trappp he qui après avoir accroché les
les play-offs la saison dernière au prix
d'une seconde partie de saison
exceptionnelle et bien l'exercice
2012-2013 est très très compliqué ça
ressemble à un chemin de croix pour les
joueurs traapiste lanterne rouge de la
Nationale 2 avec seulement qu victoires
en 14 journées ils doivent vite se
reprendre s'ils ne veulent pas retomber
en National 3 et Mustapha désespéré pour
les résultats de trappe c'est votre
ville mais en basket ils ont quelques
difficultés on leur souhaite bien
évidemment de figurer parmi les tops
l'année prochaine merci à tous les trois
d'être venus sur ce plateau pour ce 78
sport prochain rendez-vous lundi
prochain 18h25 toujours en direct pour
un point complet oui nous consacrerons
d'ailleurs une page spéciale comme je le
disais au 64e de finale des moins de 19
ans de l'Étoile Sportive de guillancour
face à l'goser et vous pourrez découvrir
la préparation championnat de France de
box de deux boxeurs il en courtois Adil
momad chez les super moyen et Marvin
petit en catégorie léger à lundi
prochain bonne soirée